1 toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash vous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
la hausse des prix du gaz et
d'électricité touchent directement au
moins 36 millions d'européens pour la
france plus question de fermer 14
réacteurs pour réduire à 50% la part du
nucléaire 2035 l'allemagne est dans une
toute autre logique devenu club by gaz
russe en europe elle s'oppose à la
stratégie nucléaire de la france mieux à
est en crise tout cela c'est le reflet
en fait d'un conflit plus large dont
elle n'est que la proie est aujourd'hui
la victime
les français ont découvert une réalité
qui n'avait pas compris ou plutôt qu'on
ne leur avait pas expliqué
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité mais idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine françois vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire bernard friot et frédéric
lordon sont deux références
intellectuelles et politiques l'un et
l'autre sont déjà venus séparément dans
cette émission je suis heureux de les
accueillir ensemble aujourd'hui et on
débat l'occasion de la sortie de leur
livre intitulé en travail ce sont vos
conversations sur le communisme ça vient
de paraître à la dispute vos
trajectoires respectives convergent en
effet sur la nécessité d'une proposition
communiste mais laquelle de quel
communisme par le ton à quoi ça
ressemblerait c'est ce que l'on nous
allons voir je vous les présente d'abord
plus en détail bernard friot vous êtes
économiste
aimé professeur émérite à l'université
paris-x nanterre sociologue également
sociologue du travail membre du parti
communiste français depuis 1969 c'est
vous qui avait théorisé le salaire à la
qualification personnelle qu'on appelle
aussi le salaire à vie vous étiez venu
en débat sur cette question dans cette
émission il ya deux ans vous êtes
l'auteur de très nombreux livres dont
l'enjeu du salaire allait disputent un
désir de communisme un livre
d'entretiens avec judith bernard aux
éditions textuel ou puissance du
salariat récemment paru en poche dans la
collection points c'est bien le mot
communisme à votre avis qu'il faut
mettre sur la table il figure dans
plusieurs titres de vos lui livre c'est
également le cas chez frédéric lordon
mais est ce que ce mot communiste qui
est quand même lourd de sens aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est bien lui qu'il faut
utiliser d'après vous en quelques mots
en tout cas pas anticapitaliste ni post
capitalisme post capitaliste que samoa
c'est assez vide et qu'on ne peut se
mobiliser que pour quelque chose pas
pour rien et
anticapitalistes parce que certes
sortir du capitalisme suppose être
anticapitaliste mais ça peut nous
introduire à une analyse
non dialectique du capitalisme dans
lequel il ya une espèce de structures
qui se reproduit qui génère des victimes
et de ne pas voir le communisme déjà là
dans le capitalisme même et communisme
donc bah oui parce que
nous nous avons à à mettre en commun la
décision en matière de production et de
travail qui pour le moment est le
monopole d'une bourgeoisie qui fasse
maintenant une conscience assez
majoritaire nous mène dans le mur d'eau
sur aussi bien d'un point de vue
écologique que d'un point de vue
anthropologique
trailer dont vous avez été économiste
vous êtes philosophe directeur de
recherche au cnrs vous dernier livre son
vivre sans point d'interrogation
institutions police travail argent bon
livre pour lequel vous étiez venu dans
cette émission il y ait deux ans et
figure du communisme les deux sont parus
à la fabrique lors même question est ce
que c'est le mot est ce que ce mot
communisme c'est celui qu'il faut à
votre on n'est pas complètement idiot on
se rend compte que le signifiant
communiste et lesté d'un certain d'un
certain poids d'une certaine charge
historique et symbolique
nous persistons malgré tout sur la base
je viens de deux arguments le premier
qui pourrait sembler paradoxal mais que
je crois que nous pouvons tenir il
consisterait à dire que communisme n'a
jamais eu lieu également le le discours
ordinaire tient que le communisme a été
réalisée en urs dans le bloc de l'est en
chine etc etc mais ceux ci n'avaient
rien à voir avec le communisme en tout
cas avec ce que nous entendons par
communisme d'ailleurs dans l'urss il ya
le premier s voulait dire socialisme je
sais toujours pas trop ce que ça veut
dire moi socialisme communisme on sert
non c'est un petit peu mieux donc c'est
la première des choses c'est de
débarrasser le signifiant de cette
charge historique qui ne lui revient pas
historiographique m'en parle en deuxième
chose c'est que bien sûr le mot est
chargé mais le regard qu'on jette sur
insignifiant peut varier
considérablement dans le temps et
parfois même à très grande vitesse en
particulier dans les périodes comme la
période présente et période de crise
profonde que gramsci qualifié de crise
organique ou des déplacements fulgurant
peuvent avoir lieu alors il ya vingt ans
encore
dire capitalisme était vraiment été ccc
c'était être stigmatisés comme une
espèce de dinosaure totalement archaïque
et c'est maintenant le capitalisme fait
partie du discours commun il ya cinq dix
ans le mot bourgeoisie lui aussi faisait
de vous une espèce de débris tirés des
décombres des années rouges ces années
soixante dix désormais la catégorie de
bourgeoisie circulent de nouveau dans le
discours sous des élaborations
théoriques
empirique très sérieuse ou chance au
travail de bruno amable et stefano
palombarini pour élaborer la catégorie
de bloc bourgeois alors bien sûr le
signifiant communisme n'en est pas
encore là mais je serais tenter de vous
donner rendez vous dans dix ans ça
pourrait bien avoir changé alors parlons
du capitalisme justement en cette année
2009 21 bientôt 2022 après deux ans de
pandémie le capitalisme en plus on est
près noël et noël c'est un moment très
particulier c'est une véritable fête
capitaliste avec des dés décoration des
vitrines des inégalités aussi qu'ils
sont peut-être plus criante au moment de
noël j'aurais voulu savoir comment vous
voyez cette période du capitalisme l'un
comme l'autre
angoisse qui le frappent comme mais
connaisseur du travail 1 c c'est quand
même une perte d'adhésion à la
production et au travail tel que la
bourgeoisie capitale organise même chez
des cadres qui était
finalement très très adhérents à leur
entreprise toutes les enquêtes montrent
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui une attitude
plutôt cynique il n'y a pas forcément de
deux défections mais y'a plus d'adhésion
est paraît-il des défections aux états
unis où il ya beaucoup de salariés qui
ont quitté leur entreprise alors des
défections je parlais des cadres et
dirigeants mais alors là des défections
on en a à la pelle dans toute une série
de jeunesse unie dissidente qui ne veut
pas travailler pour le capitalisme ça
c'est clair
il me semble aussi que la la le
coronavirus la façon dont il est géré
d'une part à montrer
l'extrême importance de dissocier la
rémunération de l'activité et ça c'est
très porteur je pense d'avenir on s'est
rendu compte que si c'est notre activité
valide et socialement comme productifs
qui décident de nos revenus bas en cas
de raid activités basse c'est la mère
des enfants et il ya un effondrement
économique alors qu'il a été
complètement éviter parce qu'on avait
fait cette dissociation qui est au coeur
du du salaire comme ulysse tels que nous
l'analysons dents sur lequel on
reviendra effectivement le communisme ce
que vous appelez vous le communisme déjà
là frédéric lordon sur la situation du
capitalisme et pourquoi pas puisque vous
l'aborder dans le livre avec les
élections présidentielles qui se pointe
et où on voit que c'est plutôt quelqu'un
comme marine le pen qui aujourd'hui et
recueille les intentions de vote des
classes populaires bon si vous voulez
vous aussi vous voulez me faire parler
d'eux
de l'élection présidentielle j'ai peur
de décevoir vos
questions écoutez je vais vous dire moi
j'ai fait il ya pas longtemps j'ai fait
un neveu qui est le voeu de radoter je
vous prie de l'en excuser donc je vais
dire des choses que j'ai dit avant je
veux dire ici et je les dirai plus tard
jeanne annonce la couleur je il faudra
doter parce que il y a comment dirais-je
les déplacements dans les esprits se
font à force de répétition donc voila
moi mon radotage il prend la forme d'un
syllogisme qui s'énonce qui qui procède
en 4 énoncé premier énoncé il y à un
écocide ont faim je pense que maintenant
c'est une idée qui commence à avoir
suffisamment gagné du terrain dans dans
la société deuxième énoncé l'écocide et
capitaliste donc il faut qu'on arrête de
nous bassiner avec l'anthropocène la
cause de l'ecosite ça n'est pas l'homme
avec un grand h c'est le capitalisme et
des hommes du capitalisme troisième
énoncés il n'y a pas de solution
capitaliste à l'écossé capitaliste alors
j'insiste particulièrement sur ce 3ème
et non c'est parce que c'est si vous
voulez il ya là un thème avec lequel on
s'apprête à nous promener pendant au
minimum une si c'est pas deux décennies
et peut-être davantage parce que le
capital cherche à gagner du temps à cet
égard moi je voudrais parler d'un livre
qui m'a dit m'a beaucoup marqué qui est
un livre qui a été fait par hélène
tordjman qui est une collègue de
l'époque où j'étais économistes qui
s'appelle la croissance verte contre les
la nature et qui est une démolition
méthodique de la fausse promesse du
capitalisme de réparer lui-même ses
petites salissures
première énoncée d'un écocide deuxième
les capitalistes troisième ya pas de
solution capitaliste à l'ecosite
capitaliste ergo conclusion si on veut
mettre un terme au cours du désastre qui
des trucs de de la planète qui part en
morceaux il faut sortir du capitalisme
et comme l'a dit bernard tout à l'heure
communisme et le nom positif qui
correspond à cette norme et sortir du
capitalisme ça dépassait retire de la
production donc ça n'est pas sortir non
plus de la consommation d'énergie dont
les émissions de co2 dans l'atmosphère
provoque
le réchauffement climatique alors oui et
non
nous nous portons une attention
particulière à la question de la
production des forces productives mais
nous soustrayons radicalement cette
question aux cadres du productivisme
c'est à dire ou cadre du développement
intransitive des forces productives
qu'on développe pour les développer en
réalité pour accroître toujours
davantage la rentabilité pour les
propriétaires du capital mais en effet
sortir du capitalisme ne nous dispense
pas de pourvoir à notre reproduction
matériels à l'échelle d'une communauté
est tendue avec une division du travail
qui si elle en rabattre a
considérablement restera suffisamment
profondes toutes ces choses doit s'en
viennent doivent s'organiser et met sous
la contrainte de la planète à préserver
kaki poser en premier lieu qui est
hiérarchiquement supérieures tout le
reste lui étant subordonnée donc ça ça
fait partie de tout de toute la
réflexion faisait allusion aux élections
présidentielles parce que vous dites
frédéric lordon dans vos entretiens
que dès l'instant où le capitalisme se
délabre c'est toujours l'extrême droite
qui en profite vous êtes d'accord avec
cette assertion d'ailleurs paraphe rio
maintien pu encore une fois d'adhésion à
ce vers quoi nous conduit le capitalisme
c'est un temps qui est risquée parce que
il ya on a un peu déboussolés on adhère
plus à ce à quoi on adhérait et donc
l'extrême droite peut venir mais aussi
le communisme
amont le dessus oui moi je joue
effectivement je je je je soutiens cette
thèse parce que le l'ordre capitaliste
est en train d'arriver à sliimy nous le
chantons la décomposition d'un ordre
social c'est aussi la décomposition d'un
ordre symbolique dont les repères se se
délite et dans le désencrage général la
déréliction qui règne qui se répand
partout le niveau de l'angoissé monte et
la proposition fasciste a objectivement
des propriétés anxiolytiques elle
restaure une certaine image de l'ordre
social
et comme elle va au plus simple si c'est
également au plus ignoble elle peut
gagner beaucoup d'adhésions et en effet
dans sedan dans cet affrontement là il
faut jouer propositions contre
propositions c'est à dire il faut
avancer contre la proposition fasciste
il faut avancer une refiguration
d'ensemble de l'ordre social alternative
et au capitalisme et au fascisme alors
revenons en à à quoi ressemblerait le
communisme que dont vous parlez tous les
deux dans ce livret est l'un des mérites
justement de vos entretiens c'est de
voir ce communisme parce que très
souvent quand on parle de communisme
aujourd'hui on évoque le mot et on se
dispense de le décrire or comme on le
disait au début de cette émission le
communisme a laissé un certain nombre
d'image qui sont plutôt des images
sombres des images des gative que ce
soit des images de goulag des images
d'invasion des images de de l'armée
rouge des images des
maoïstes chinois des gars de rouge c'est
l'uniformisation c'est la justice c'est
les pénuries aujourd'hui le capitalisme
dans votre image alors d'abord est ce
que en quoi c'est en quoi je vous
l'avais dit tout à l'heure vous lever
esquissé en quoi ça ça n'est pas le
communisme justement puisque vous êtes
d'accord tous les deux et ensuite vous
me direz à quoi ressemblerait le
communisme dont vous parlez bernard
friot ça n'est pas le communiste parce
que le communiste peut se construire
qu'à partir de la prise du pouvoir
des citoyens sur la production et sur le
travail qu une fois il ya d'autres
dimensions du communisme et comme
économiste du travail celui du travail
c'est sur ce champ là que je réfléchisse
or on est victime je pense ça vraiment
d'une d'une culture militante qui le dit
que
aller aux communes isséens prendre le
pouvoir d'état 2 construire le
socialisme trois camps sur le communisme
selon une une métaphore qui est très
religieuse en passe de l'autre côté puis
elle purgatoire puis elle part à dix ans
ça c'est extrêmement mortifère cette
affaire c'est très mortifère parce que
si on prend le pouvoir d'état alors que
les travailleurs dans le camp pas pris
le pouvoir sur le travail la classe
dirigeante la bourgeoisie capitaliste
mais elle tient en otage la société
puisque c'est elle qui tient les clés de
la production et donc de deux choses
l'une soit l'état en question
renonce
nous avons en france cette histoire à
deux le prise du pouvoir d'état par la
gauche passe dans mitterrand en 81 et
puis en 82 83 legrand renoncement et ça
s'est poursuivi
depuis 40 ans de façon régulière
soit soit on instaure une dictature face
à l'as à la réaction du capital sauf que
cette dictature votre dictature sur le
peuple puisque c'était est arrivé d'une
part avec l'illusion qu'on va faire part
en eau des bonnes choses avec un bon
état et puis sans qu'il y ait eu cette
préparation par les travailleurs eux
mêmes de la prise de pouvoir sur le
travail est donc cet inévitable que l'on
se retrouve avec mitterrand avec staline
si on raisonne comme cela ce n'est pas
le communisme en aucun cas le communisme
peut venir que par le communisme c'est à
dire par encore une fois un changement
du statut des personnes du statut
économique des personnes de sorte
qu'elle et les droits et les
responsabilités
de
décider de la production ce qui est le
coeur du communisme avec laure dont vous
me donnez l'occasion de revenir sur ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure je disais le
communisme n'a pas eu lieu en tout cas
il ne correspond pas à ce qui figurent
dans les livres d'histoire ordinairement
sous cette étiquette des expériences
communiste il y en a eu tout de même on
pourrait parler de la catalogne en 1936
de ce qui se passe actuellement
depuis quelques décennies d'ailleurs au
chiapas ou rhodia bas mais ce sont des
expériences ils sont tellement
singulière qu'elles sont pas
immédiatement transposables dans les
coordonnées de notre situation la raison
pour laquelle je suis absolument
d'accord avec ce que vous avez dit ils
font que nous produisions des images il
faut qu'une produits vision des figures
pour donner à voir et presqu'à sentir à
quoi ça pourrait ressembler moi je
dirais la chose suivante si vous voulez
le du la formule synthétique de
l'intention communiste pourrait être
celle qui s'énonce ainsi relevé les
humains et la planète des souffrances
qui leur ont été imposées par le
capitalisme en commençant par les
humains si possible qu'est ce que c'est
des souffrances des humains dans
l'enrôlement du travail capitaliste il y
en a deux essentiellement il ya la
précarité et il ya la perte de sens du
travail la précarité est bon alors là la
réponse communiste et celle que bernard
a élaboré depuis très longtemps déjà un
c'est la réponse du salaire à vie du
salaire à la qualification personnelle
c'est-à-dire une formule qui découple le
revenu la rémunération de l'activité les
effets sont considérables si vous voulez
ça relève les gens de leur angoisse de
l'angoissé de la précarité matérielle
des fins de mois du plan social qui va
vous tomber sur le coin de la cafetière
de désaccord de performance collective
des ordonnances macron du cdd de
l'intérim etc etc c'est vraiment un
changement de monde à une chose pareille
et le la démolition du sens au travail
là aussi c'est pareil en réalité vous
savez les gens
aiment bien faire leur travail et désire
être placé dans les conditions qui leur
permettent de le faire bien or ces
conditions le capitalisme actionnarial
les mouz y y méthodiquement il ya une
éthique du travail allait chez les
travailleurs les patchs et les
capitalistes n'est pas dans le
capitalisme on est là aussi la réponse
la réponse que nous apportons est
extrêmement simple c'est la souveraineté
des producteurs sur l'organisation de
production c'est tout à fait décisif si
vous voulez il ya une chose qui est
quand même tout à fait étonnante à
laquelle on prête presque pas attention
j'ai l'impression le rapport salarial
capitaliste est défini juridiquement
comme rapport de subordination
hiérarchique c'est à dire comme un
rapport d'obéissance ce qui signifie que
les rapports sociaux de production sous
le capitalisme sont de type féodal et
bien le communisme c'est la proposition
de faire entrée la production dans son
entièreté dans un régime de démocratie
intégrale quand vous dites c'est audel
vous exagérez sous effet de l'it et on
ne pouvait pas partir aujourd'hui on
peut oui mais vous voyez c'est une
fausse promesse celle du départ il fait
froid sur le marché du travail 1 en ce
moment donc le rapport salarial en
réalité est un rapport de chantage à la
survie matérielle mais capitaliste le
savent très bien et si vous faites
connaître votre dissentiment dans
l'entreprise au bout d'un certain moment
on vous montrera la porte et vous serez
obligé soin de vous affaler soit de
l'apprendre faudrait qu'on s'arrête
justement sur le communisme que vous
qualifiez de déjà là bernard friot
là vous le ramener à lavau études
longues sur la sécurité sociale et ce au
fond ce serait c'est ce sont les
syndicats communistes c'est la cgt qui
tenait la sécurité sociale aux débuts en
1946 avec ce beau slogan fermons la
porte à la misère et vous dites que tout
ce que nous verse la sécu que ce soit
les remboursements de nos frais de santé
le chômage la retraite ou pendant le coc
vide les
l'essentiel l'intégralité 90% des
revenus des gens qui étaient obligés de
rester chez eux au fond c'est une c'est
un salaire communiste la sécurité
sociale nous verse à salers communisme
on est déjà dans le communisme là ça n'a
rien à voir avec le salaire capitaliste
qu on peut par ailleurs touché pour en
fonction de son emploi
le salaire capitaliste c'est la
reconnaissance des besoins d'un
supporter pour faire telle tâche qui est
validée comme productif par le par le
marché des biens et services et
ça nous
s'introduit un aléa puisque la
validation de nos tâches comme
productives c'est pas nous qui en
décidant et puis elle est forcément
aléatoire et puis c'est d'ailleurs
important que tout otages sont pas
productives moi je suis très attaché à
ce que toute une partie de nos activités
sort de la valeur sauf que dans le
capitalisme nous sommes reconnus comme
travailleurs avec un salaire à la mesure
de ses activités aléatoire et
intermittente et tout l'enjeu du
mouvement ouvrier vous avez fait
allusion à 46 mais c'est tout l'enjeu du
xxème siècle ouvriers c'est de dissocier
comme l'a rappelé frédéric le salaire de
l'activité de la mesure de l'activité
c'est l'invention de la qualification
dans les conventions collectives les
commensaux collective entre 1919 et 1975
en gros un seul grand essor des
conventions collectives
consiste à apprendre tous les postes
d'une même branche
et quelle que soit l'activité qui lie
aux postes les rangées par niveau de
qualification et de salaire et la
qualification de pas la mesure de
l'activité que l'on fait du tout hein
c'est la mesure du travail concret que
l'on fait c'est pas ça c'est la mesure
de la production de valeur liée à ce
poste et
c'est ce qui va permettre vous l'avez
rappelé pour ceux qui avaient un emploi
lié à la convention collective d'avoir
eu 84 % de leur salaire quelles qu'aient
été leurs activités parce que c'est
c'est la qualification du poste qui est
payé c'est pas l'activité qui est menée
et alors dans la fonction publique c'est
bien plus c'est pour ça que les
fonctionnaires -sur conserver la
totalité de leur salaire
la qualification n'est pas attribuée au
poste comme dans l'emploi et l'a
attribuée à la personne même dans le
grade si bien que les fonctionnaires
d'ailleurs de leur ôtant la force
publique jusqu'à leur mort sont payés
pour leur qualification personnelle
quels que soient les aléas de leur
activité est ce assez c'est une
condition du communisme je pas comment
nous pouvons devenir souverain sur la
production aussi bien micro que macro la
décision de création monétaire qu'elle
qu'elle veut qu'est-ce qu'on va investir
quelle division du travail etc 6 nous
sommes dans l'allée a permanent de nos
ressources il faut et et dans la
suspicion que ce que nous faisons n'est
pas productif il faut que nous soignons
projet est confirmé en permanence comme
en capacité 2 et en responsabilité de
produire la valeur c'est pas une
condition suffisante de salaire à la
qualification personnelle mais c'est une
condition nécessaire de déjà là
communisme ce salaire à la qualification
personnelle vous le calcul est à 1700
euros nets au minimum à partir du 18 ans
c'est un droit un droit politique et au
maximum à 5000 euros nets donc trois
fois il ya évidemment il serait
requalifier en fonction des progrès
qu'on peut faire tous les dix ans ou
tous les quinze ans on déciderait alors
ça c'est là où est le problème qui
déciderait si on est augmentée ou pas
est-ce que ce sont nos pères mais nos
pères sont pas forcément très très bon
jugement les journalistes par exemple je
peux vous dire qu'il me moque montrait
que jamais
c'est un peu souvent que ça arrive comme
ça qu'est ce que vous en pensez en deux
mots frédéric lordon sachant que c'est
une proposition qui vous a séduite mais
oui mais maintenant mais moi je veux la
kali la qualification par les pairs mais
bernard y est soumis autant que moi
l'universitaire les milieux de la
recherche c'est ça qui nous arrive moi
en l'occurrence c'est pas la question
des pères je pense qu'effectivement il
doit y avoir des commissions c'est
bernard le l'évoquent quand dans ses
schémas d'organisation institutionnelle
du communisme les commissions de la
qualification qui effectivement qui
réunisse toutes sortes de toutes sortes
de membres porteur de toutes sortes de
qualité avec évidemment aussi d'aider
des conditions liées à la rotation des
mandats la révocabilité des
représentants etc etc mais oui il faudra
se soumettre effectivement au jugement
de commissions et les commissions étant
des institutions humaines et les unes
des institutions humaines étant
imparfaite ce seront des lieux où
s'exprimeront des conflits et de la
violence mais une société il n'y a pas
de tels lieux où s'exprime la violence
ça n'existe pas donc notre choix c'est
d'agencer les institutions de la manière
qui soit la plus vertueuse ou la moins
mal foutu possible mais en effet c'est
comme ça que ça se passera
et on le sait bien
intel a été requalifiée pas moi il y
aura de la jalousie y aura du soupçon il
y aura les passions humaines ordinaire
oui ça sera comme ça je peux permettre à
bout j'ai trouvé intéressant d'ailleurs
que ça y est de 1,3 jeu quand on me
demande c'est quoi la richesse je dis
toujours et riche celui qui gagne trois
fois plus que toi bah voilà donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya encore des riches dans
votre dans votre société communiste
celui qui était au premier échelon verra
celui qui est au troisième celui qui
tamisent 700 euros par mois net vers à
celui qui gagne 5000 euros net comme un
riche
bien égouttés c'est encore une fois moi
je ne je ne crois pas au paradis un au
paradis communiste ou saas pour moi
c'est de la blague
ce qui ce qui importe comme le rappelle
frédéric c2c de gérer la violence
sociale
bien sûr que un rapport de un à trois
qui est quand même déjà vraiment très
grosse une énorme différence avec les
rapports que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui alors ça s'inspire des
rapport interdécile 1 le rapport
interdécile dans la fonction publique ou
dans les conventions collectives
négociées
c'est à dire le rapport entre la moyenne
des 10 % et plus faibles salaires et la
moyenne des 10 % des plus forts salaires
il est en gros 2 à 3 mais entre les
salaires elle il peut être effectivement
deux habiles ou 10000
sachant qu'ensuite via les impôts qui en
france quand même réduisent l'écart mis
un petit oui bien sûr alors maintenant
sur
le fait qu'il y ait à une hiérarchie des
qualifications
si pour moi il ya deux raisons l'une qui
empirique 1 a pas d'humour nous sommes
tous titulaires d'un salaire comme
droits politiques
il n'est pas sûr que notre notre désir
de trajectoires professionnelles
rejoignent les besoins sociaux il faut
bien un ajustement qui peut se faire par
une hiérarchie des salaires qui fait que
quelqu'un qui travaillera deux nuits
dans industries de process ou à
l'hôpital avec une
un axe une activité qui nuit quand même
à sa santé montre ap le vide en
qualifications par exemple et puis la
deuxième raison qui elle est profonde
c'est qu'il ya du tragique dans la
société et que
[Musique]
gérer les pouvoirs de violents les
violences les pouvoirs qu'il y a dans
toute activité de production
l'argent est une bonne façon de
d'objectiver les rapports sociaux et
donc
gérer ces rapports par une hiérarchie
des salaires ça a du sens alors c'est
pas je ne sais pas c'est pas le paradis
mais encore une fois elle frédéric et
moi on est absolument d'accord là-dessus
tout anthropologie enchanté sur le
communisme nous mène au désastre
on fait une pause et puis après on va
développer quand même parce que vous
donnez beaucoup d'autres images a bien
entendu de ce communisme ce n'est pas
seulement une question de salaire on se
retrouve dans deux minutes
cette semaine on va passer en revue
l'actualité économique qu'une bonne
partie des économistes qui pensent que
tout ce qui a été fait a été bien fait
que structurellement l'économie va bien
que chômage a vraiment été vaincue que
le pib a augmenté moi je vois pas où
sont les fondamentaux qui sont bons ben
non justement problème c'est que la
bourse est le monde simplement parce que
les banques centrales injectent de
l'argent le monde entier sous perfusion
là on a un vrai problème on ne sait pas
comment débrancher la perfusion quand
vous déversez comme ça et que vous
endetter pour faire 5 10 % de déficit
budgétaire
évidemment vous avez un résidu qui
arrive en pipe et heureusement faut
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles et leur annoncer à chaque fois
que demain l'herbe est plus verte parce
que demain malheureusement l'herbe elle
est moche
la situation politique d'abord c'est
quoi votre analyse de cette espèce de
tsunami
les choses commencent à s'organiser plus
entre deux poules ou trois peut-être la
france elle est entre la droite et
l'extrême droite on peut pas éviter ce
constat la situation politique va se
passer à droite et sur des thématiques
de droite ça veut dire par exemple que
votre candidat est obligé de durcir ses
positions de droite l'idée de cette
primaire interne c'était de créer à
l'arrivée l'équipe de france et l'équipe
de france elle est là c'est la première
fois première fois dans l'histoire de
france qu'une femme selon les sondages
peut être élue présidente de la
république c'est sans doute une
révolution qui permet de dire que le
plafond de verre a peut être enfin
exploser
on repose cette émission sur le
communisme oui je sais le mot est fort
avec bernard friot et frédéric lordon
frédéric lordon la parole et est à vous
on était dans le salaire tels que
bernard friot l'a théorisé le salaire à
vie
qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres dans ce
communisme pour vous qui est
indispensable parce qu'il n'ya pas que
les salaires et non non non non mais non
bien sûr
la question générale de la production ça
n'est pas seulement la question du
salaire et tout à l'heure je disais la
vocation du communisme c'est de relever
les humains et la planète des violences
qui leur sont faites par le par le
capitalisme
j'ai parlé de celles qui sont faites aux
personnes aux personnes salariées mais
il faut pas il faut parler également de
celles qui sont faites à la planète qui
en réalité ils viennent en premier au
premier rang de nos préoccupations
et cet égard je pense qu'il ya basée
dans le prolongement finalement directe
de ce que je disais à propos de l'entrée
des rapports sociaux de production dans
l'ère de la démocratie intégrale
mais elle a parlé tout à l'heure de la
souveraineté à la fois microéconomiques
et macroéconomiques sur le sur la
production je pense et c'est un point
qui est tout à fait fondamental dans le
capitalisme la production n'est soumise
qu'à la validation du marché
sous la gouverne évidemment du critère
de rentabilité pour les actionnaires bon
dans le communisme le l'intégralité de
la production entre dans un régime où la
validation des rives d'une délibération
in fine et d'une décision collective
politique à tous les niveaux où il est
pertinent que ces délibérations
s'effectuer que ses décisions soient
prises ce qui signifie et alors là vous
allez voir la différence avec le le
communisme épouvantail de du débat
public ce qui signifie que
cette décision n'appartient pas du tout
exclusivement à l'état et lui revient
pour la part qui correspond à ses
prérogatives propres de coordination au
niveau macroéconomique au niveau macro
sociale mais la délibération et la
décision politique quant aux
orientations de la production elle se
décompose en une série d' instances
territoriales
qui sont jugées les plus pertinentes
relativement à la question qui leur sont
soumises je veux dire si par exemple la
question c'est mettre tel terres en
culture ou bien la réserve et mettre
telle forêt en exploitation ou bien en
protection monter tels circuits de
retraitement des déchets ou
d'approvisionnement maraîchers etc on
voit bien que ce n'est pas le gosplan
année l'état central qui va s'en charger
n'est ce pas ce seront des commissions
ce sont des commissions locales est
toujours en ayant à répondre à une
question finalement unique qui est la
question de savoir de trancher quant à
ce dont nous avons réellement besoin
sous contrainte que la planète puisse le
supporter qui signifie que la le critère
de la de la viabilité écologique en
quelque sorte vient en premier il reste
ça juste mais c'est pas dans le
capitalisme n'est ce pas c'est tout à
l'envers alors là il faudrait rentrer
dans le détail les hommes de des
institutions qui opère tout qui opèrent
tous et toutes ces délibérations et qui
correspondent en fait à ce que bernard
dans ses travaux antérieurs appelé les
caisses économique on insiste beaucoup
sur le pluriel moi je veux même parler
du système des caisses économique pour
souligner le fait que nous avons là
affaire à une architecture
institutionnelle à multiples étages et
qui n'est pas du tout analysé dans
l'état central comme comme dans la
version stalinienne du socialisme une
multiplicité de
des tâches pour une architecture qui est
organisée selon des principes de
dévolution
d'autonomie et de subsidiarité maximale
dans une architecture d'ensemble à
caractère fortement fédéraliste et ce
sont ces commissions qui vont décider du
pilotage de la division du travail c'est
à dire qu'ils vont décider ce qu'on va
faire ce qu'on va arrêter de faire ce
qu'on va faire davantage parce qu'il le
faut et c'est je veux dire par exemple
si si un collectif se serait sûrement un
gros collectif se pointait disait alors
nous on a un super projet on va
développer des circuits intégrés très
très sophistiqués pour que les voitures
reconnaissent leurs propriétaires à 10
mètres et ouvre automatiquement les
portières bon je veux dire la commission
le redirai vraisemblablement écouter des
imbécilités pareil vraiment on attention
risquerait de répondre la même chose à
celui qui inventerait le smartphone
abbas et non mais c'est possible c'est
très possible ce effectivement même
vraisemblance est très vraisemblable et
je vais vous dire c'est même très
souhaitable c'est à dire que le
l'appareil de la génération d'après du
smartphone effectivement la question ça
sera de savoir si on en a besoin s'il
faut expliquer une première génération
du smartphone et attend tout à côté des
belles téléphone mais les lignes 1 à
ressembler à une télé puis 1 aura un
ordinateur exactement bon je dire là la
patte est sortie du tube de dentifrice
on peut pas les faire rentrer mais on
peut arrêter d'appuyer sur tous les
tubes de dentifrice les spams et c'est
bien ça effectivement qui est l'essence
de l'essence des formations plus clair
d'abord première question est ce que
vous abolissez la propriété privée parce
que c'est très gentil de réduire les
salaires à 3 mais elle est inégalités de
patrimoine je pense que ça va pas durer
longtemps
on va pas laisser les gens avec des
patrimoines considérable alors qu'on a
réduit les salaires de tout le monde ce
serait fort injuste d'ailleurs que les
zones continue de profiter de la
richesse de l'or leurs ancêtres pendant
que les plus jeunes travailleurs ne
peuvent plus s'enrichir est ce qu'on
continue d'avoir des entreprises et ce
qui est de la concurrence
alors la réponse est oui à tout ça je
pense c'est à dire que
dès lors qu'un patrimoine d'un
patrimoine d'usagé du zajec il ne sert
pas c'est pas une propriété lucrative
dont on tire un revenu que
des enfants héritent d'une maison
familiale me paraît tout à fait légitime
je me souviens d'un texte dé des pinçon
charlot qui avait assisté à une
destruction 1 dans la loi borloo borloo
qui détruit des des grandes barres au
nom de sherpas coiffe est surtout au nom
du capitalisme immobilier pour
l'essentiel à avec des habitants de ces
barquettes invités à observer le
spectacle et qui était
d'une tristesse infinie et une dizaine
enfin pouvoir avoir une profondeur
familiale sur un certain nombre de 2,2
de biens comme une commune maison mais
c'est important enfin c'est pas on n'est
pas il est venu de rien n'est ni nulle
part donc vous voyez bien que si nous
sommes à 5000 euros maximum de
ressources par par mois puisque la peau
lors on ne peut plus avoir de ressources
liées à la propriété la propriété
d'usagés possibles mais pas la propriété
lucrative on va pouvoir accumuler des
trucs de manière intergénérationnel à
des niveaux a descend pas du tout alors
on va être dans une si on peut plus
garder l'immeuble qu'on avait hérité de
son grand-père évidemment à cela vous
abolissez la propriété privée on peut le
garder à titre de propriété des usages
mais on ne peut pas si on le vend bien
la peau claire hui le prix de la vente
va ou si on le loue le prix de la vente
et de la location va à la sécurité
sociale du logement
que l'on met en place comme la solution
neeskens la concurrence ah oui oui non
mais c'est le d'abord il faut il faut il
y avait plusieurs questions dans votre
question vous deviez l'abolition de la
propriété privée et des patrimoines vous
voyez il ya les possessions personnel
puis à la propriété était privée des
moyens de production ce qui correspond à
ce que bernard appelle la propriété
lucrative celles ci ont l'abolît mais
sans la moindre hésitation c'est la
condition sine qua none pour
l'instauration de la souveraineté des
producteurs sur sur leur outil de
production c'est qu'ils n'appartiennent
plus à un capitaliste n'est ce pas alors
maintenant il ya la question marché
monnaie concurrence etc oui nous
maintenons tout cela est alors
évidemment nous passons pour nous nous
ne passons pour des mécréants auprès
d'eux auprès d'une bonne partie de
l'église communiste marxiste qui tient
que la vraie formule du communisme c'est
de chacun selon ses capacités à chacun
selon ses besoins et nous nous
considérons que c'est une formule
d'harmonie anthropologique spontané il
n'y croyons pas et puis une autre chose
avec elle une croyance et que nous
aurons à trouver une combinaison des
modes de coordination économique à
régler de manière assez fine dans
laquelle il entrera une partie de
planification pour réduire quand même
aussi considérablement que possible la
part du marché pour piloter la
réparation écologique mais qu' il ne
saurait être question que toutes les
activités productives des personnes des
collectifs soit enrégimentés dans une
planification unique totalisante
centralisée obtient une licence privée
alors voilà exactement c'est à dire que
nous on serait pas loin là enfin 17 mai
où il élevait enfin voilà c'est ça on
serait pas loin de dire même si ça peut
paraître paradoxal que nous plaidons
pour un communisme de l'initiative
privée ça fait bizarre n'est-ce pas et
de mots ensemble dans le même discours
et ça c'est une des signes de victoire
si vous voulez de l'hégémonie
capitaliste qui a réussi à mettre la
main comme ça sur un certain nombre de
catégories s'est approprié valeurs dont
on a assez parlé un bernard salaires
également travaille également
initiatives privées non l'initiative
privée qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire des gens ont envie de faire
des choses ça c'est très bien je veux
dire il ya des choses que des gens
auront envie de faire qui s'inséreront
spontanément dans la division du travail
sous conditions de la délibération dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure s'ils veulent
nous faire un nouveau logiciel de
reconnaissance faciale de totalement
sophistiqués on les enverra se faire
voir chez plumeau donc mai si des gens
arriver dix mois voilà je voudrais nous
voudrions développer un laboratoire low
tech ou nouveaux circuits
d'approvisionnement maraîchers ou un
garage collectif etc ça fait partie et
on a envie de faire ça nous ensemble
mais mais bienvenu l'initiative
désirante des individus nous la tenons
pour le moteur de la vitalité du mesnil
ce quand je parle de concurrence et vous
veillez bien à ce qu'on a pu reprocher
au communisme soviétique notamment c'est
que tout le monde avait le même manteau
moche voilà il n'y avait qu'une voix
douala voit la chose
c'est que
l'initiative privée ça va jusqu'à ce
qu'on puisse faire ce costume là est le
vôtre
je tourne à un choix mais c'est marrant
parce que vous preniez cette question de
dudu vêtements parce que moi elle me
tient elle me tient à coeur je m'en
viens billets que vous ça va sans dire
mais taux nominaux messi mais je veux
dire il faut que des gens puissent et
auront envie de fabriquer des meubles
des montres des vêtements de ce que vous
voulez et d'autres personnes auront vite
fait de se les procurer car il ya un
désir de singularité individuelle combat
pas qu'on va pas écraser donc
effectivement dans la caricature du
communisme on peut attacher les
wagonnets un communisme goulag gosplan
lada saucisson et patates appartements
et collectifs etc et roubles ce ne sera
que du bonheur
exactement non ça n'a rien à voir avec
avec avec cette caricature se met alors
c'est là qu'on voit combien par exemple
la sécurité seules du soin et a déjà la
communiste parce que nous avons bien un
rapport marchand sur la sur la carte
vitale ya de la monnaie c'est de la mode
et marquez ne peut dépenser coop est
posée conventionnés mais nous avons dit
libéraux nous avons des libéraux et nous
avons des dés la possibilité de choix
les
et alors qui parfois est fictive des
leurs qui a eu des airs médical mais ça
c'est pas
c'est ce que le capitalisme a fait de ce
merveilleux invention la succursale du
soin dans les années 60 mais nous avons
bien une liberté de choix du
professionnel auquel nous adressons
c'est absolument fondamental ça et ça
vaut pour l'alimentation savoie pour
l'habillement ça vaut pour tous je
voudrais aussi dire que les exemples que
donne frédéric sont surtout micro mais
lorsqu'il évoque les fonctions d'état à
l'échelle macro mais ces fonctions là
nous avons l'exemple de 2 prémisse
d'état communiste avec le régime général
de sécurité sociale de 46 c'est une
fonction collective qui gère
l'équivalent du budget de l'état et
c'est les travailleurs qui gère m'a
totalement parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à
éliminer ni l'état ni les patrons comme
le souhaitait la cgt en outre 45 mais il
ya quand même un exemple prodigieux la
de la fécondité d'une fonction collectif
qui est assumé par les travailleurs eux
mêmes et qui peut mettre en place pas
simplement des des équipements locaux
mais qui a mis en place à la fin des
années 50 une production nationale du
soin extrême à efficiente sans faire
appel au marché des capitaux avec des
professionnels qui avaient un salaire à
la qualification personnelle au marché
des soins de ville régulés par une
négociation avec un accord sur les
tarifs voilà des choses qui nous donne
déjà une figure de ce que pourra être la
production aussi bien locales que macro
dans une logique communiste et sur le
plan politique parce que là aussi c'est
un des traits du communisme c'est qu'on
oublie les élections ou alors il yal
parti unique est ce que dans votre
vision du communisme aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il ya des élections
politiques chantant j'ai bien compris
qu'il pouvait y en avoir à d'autres
niveaux est ce qu'il ya des élections
politiques et est ce que moi je peux
créer le parti capitaliste français et
me présenter non vous ne pourrez pas
créé le parti capitaliste français pour
une excellente raison c'est que nous
aurons aboli la propriété privée des
moyens action ce qui est un acte
juridique n'est ce pas c'est une
reformulation de la loi comme le 4 août
1789 on a aboli les privilèges donc si
vous vous pointez dans la société
présente en disant eh bien je voudrais
reconstituer une société d'ordre mais
qui serait juridiquement validé on vous
et on vous enverra vous faire voir
également quand même la commençant en
enfer à le faire voir quelqu'un qui
voudrait recréer le parti d'asie
aujourd'hui voilà par exemple même si
certains semblent visible en faire
bourgeonner sont laissons de côté parce
que sinon on va revenir dans le débat
d'animaux oui mais voilà sûrement
aujourd'hui voilà c'est ça donc non en
effet il ya qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise ce mais même dans le
système capitaliste il ya des
interdictions juridique si vous vous
pointez à la banque en disant écoutez
j'ai un projet nous sommes jeunes
moderne agressifs nous voudrions
développer la production et la
commercialisation de méthamphétamine ou
de crack à une échelle tout à fait
étendu nous avons des commerciaux très
dynamique et c'est le banquier vous dira
non c'est illégal donc ça non alors
maintenant quand à la question d d d d
élections ou de la représentation je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure il y à un
système institutionnel du communisme
avec des architectures de systèmes de
caisse dans lesquels il y à des délégués
et les délégués sa sé li sas elissa
serez vox à se contrôler ça se critique
et c'est donc bien sûr il restera des
des choses de cet ordre et ce système
institutionnel est celui par lequel
s'effectue la décision communiste mais
alors là diaby maison que ce que ce que
la question posée aux positions alors
est ce qu'elle est toléré la position
évidemment pas ça je veux pas comment il
peut
passer c'est d'évidence même mais ce que
je voulais
insisté c'est sur le fait que
nous présentons soutenant le livre parce
que c'est l'objet les institutions de
délibération de la valeur économique du
travail mais il faut aussi
d'institutions spécifiquement politique
et une simple c'est sur cela que vous
êtes les rosiers frédéric les
institutions spécifiquement aux
politiques pourquoi parce que les
travailleurs citoyens ils sont
contradictoires en réalité comme
travailleur prix dans l'ue brice d'une
technologie ils peuvent vouloir quelque
chose que comme citoyen ils ne veulent
pas parce que ça nous emmène dans une
humanité augmenter un peu farfelu ou je
sais pas quoi il faut donc bien
tranchées et il faudra bien des
institutions spécifiquement politique
qui tranche on ne peut pas confier
l'armé aux militaires on peut pas
confier l'économie aux travailleurs
uniquement c'est les travailleurs
citoyens et qu'ils doivent donc pouvoir
s'exprimer y compris
contre les intérêts de telle ou telle
entreprise etc
de telle ou telle caisse
d'investissement ou que sais-je
s'exprimer sur ce que politiquement nous
désirons donc là bien sûr qu'il faut des
institutions spécifiquement politique
mais alors comment y parvenir à ce
communisme dont nous parlons depuis le
début de cette émission et dont vous
parlé longuement dans vos livres en
particulier dans le dernier en travail
conversation sur le communisme comment y
parvenir sur qui compter vous
pour prendre cette direction qui est
quand même révolutionnaire vous l'avez
dit doit oui est ce que est ce qu'il ya
des syndicats est ce qu'il ya un parti
aujourd'hui qui vous semblent
particulièrement révolutionnaire est ce
que les gilet jaune les travailleurs
dans les entreprises vous semble très à
un tel basculement pour l'heure
certainement pas mais il ya des prémices
partout veut dire de toute façon la
transition vers le communisme ça
commence par un processus de maturation
il faut que des déplacements
s'effectuent dans les têtes nous il
absolument certain que nous rentrons
avec ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
conception pentecôtiste du communisme
c'est un truc qui tombent du haut et qui
s'abat verticalement de dans un sens
descendant sur une société qui a pas
demander grand chose et c'est bon il n'y
aura pas d' avènement du communisme s'il
n'y a pas eu préalablement formation
dans la fraction la plus large possible
de la population d'un désir de
communisme ce processus de maturation il
procède en plusieurs étapes d'abord il
ya l'étape du décrochage mais bernard on
a parlé tout à l'heure ça commence à
décrocher de tous les côtés si vous
voulez le pouvoir de mobilisation d'un
système social il repose sur le
sentiment de légitimité qu'il inspire
aux mobilisés or la légitimité du
capitalisme est en train de s'effondrer
c'est un point tout à fait important
alors il ya des gens que les gens
décrochent c'est à dire la croyance
s'effondre il décroche spirituellement
si vous me passez l'expression alors on
peut décrocher spirituellement et
continuer d'être accroché matériellement
parce qu'elle sert à gagner le loyer à
payer le crédit à rembourser etc
notez-bien carnacki mais cros
complètement qu'ils foutent leur camp et
qu'ils vont faire tout à fait autre
chose ailleurs et d'ailleurs un quelque
chose qui est tellement
anticapitaliste qu'il est déjà de
l'ordre d'une pratique communiste n'est
ce pas voilà alors la deuxième étape la
danse à mon avis c'est le fait de
franchir le pas entre le moment du
négatif et le moment de la positivité
comme on en parlait tout à l'heure c'est
à dire quand on savoir ce dont on ne
veut plus c'est une chose mais encore
faut-il après acquérir les figures où
les images de ce que nous voulons c'est
à ça que nous travaillons s'est adonné
sorte d'image maintenant moi ce que je
crois c'est que cette chose qui doit
monter du bas ne peut pas ne pas s'en
passer
par un point de cristallisation qui nuit
s'effectue duo parce que signé il vient
un moment où
se décide la refonte des structures
fondamentales de l'ordre social et ça ça
passe par des gestes des actes
instituant ur et instituant qui
appartiennent un pôle en charge des
prérogatives du maquereau politique et
du maquereau sociale et c'est cela que
conceptuellement on peut appeler un état
dont il ya forcément un moment où
se produit une confrontation
terminal décisive qui décide du
basculement dans un nouvel ordre social
qui n'est plus celui du capitalisme
révolution que ça s'appelle une ça
s'appelle une révolution et nous savons
que ceux qui ont les clés de l'ordre
social entre les mains ne les lâche pas
facilement non donc ça pourrait être une
révolution violent ça fait partie des
possibilités d'histoire c'est ça leur
plaisait mais ma question suivante vous
allez d'abord répondre à cela bernard
friot mai mais aussi est ce qu'on peut
faire ça dans un seul pays parce que c
est quand même tu es ça aussi la
tragédie du communisme tel qu'on l'a
connu au 20e siècle c'est qu'à chaque
fois la plupart des gens sont partis ont
voté avec leurs pieds comme on disait on
a dû hérisser les frontières de barbelés
est ce que le communisme est viable
autrement que sous une forme mondialisée
jeu
j'ai du mal avec cette question non pas
pour y répondre mais avec la question
elle-même c'est à dire que
certes il ya il y à un moment où le
passage aux communistes suppose à un
changement
global
et
brutale disant brutale ou au sens où il
est réunis en un coup un si court laps
de temps mais ton 89 93 pour la pour la
pour la révolution française bon mais il
n'est possible que parce qu'il ya eu une
maturation très longuement vente encore
une fois il n'est possible comme comme
communiste encore une fois on peut
instaurer une dictature sur le
prolétariat ça bien sûr un s'il n'y a
pas eu cette maturation avant mais s'il
ya eu la maturation avant il ya aucune
raison qu'elle n'ait lieu que dans un
seul pays cette maturation donc si un
pays qui
disent ont conclu cette maturation
c'est à dire une maturation fait de
prise de pouvoir sur le travail dans les
entreprises sur les dans les services
publics on sait qu'il y aura un désir
mimétique des autres pays des quads et
hermétique c'est que les autres pays
sont pris dans la même dans la même
urgence de sortir du capitalisme que
nous donc de même que la la la
bourgeoisie anglaise était la première
qui a pris le pouvoir d'état à la fin du
xviie mais elle a pu le faire sans voir
se fondre sur elle e
tout là toute l'aristocratie
mondiale parce que dans les autres pays
en france
en allemagne en autriche etc il y avait
les mêmes interrogations que caen caen
qu'en angleterre donc pas de communisme
dans un seul pays au sens où la
maturation nécessaire à l'avènement du
communisme la prise de pouvoir sur le
travail nécessaire
s'accomplit dans différents pays est le
premier pays qui qui disent on inscrit
dans l'ordre de 2 de la deûle donne 2 de
la loi macroéconomique et cetera
toute cette maturation
oui bien sûr qu'il fera face à une
conjuration internationale mais quand je
rassure international extrêmement
affaibli par le fait que dans tous les
autres pays il y aura eu cette
maturation aussi ça ne se fera pas avant
c'est pas
c'est pas une affaire volontariste le
passage aux communes i c'est pas vrai
tout cela c'est c'est là
[Musique]
l'organisation par exemple on part de la
défection actuellement bon il ya
défection mais si c'est une défection
qui restent à la marge on peut vous
finalement faire une éolienne dans son
coin ça dérange pas areva 1 donc la
défection marginale elle peut au
contraire même être un faire-valoir
involontaire du capitalisme ou alors
tous et tous ces jeunes qui avec du rsa
fond du logiciel libre baba fois ça
permet de logiciels propriétaires de le
récupérer donc il faut sortir de la
nasse toute cette dissidence tas de la
marge mais là nous avons nous a vendu du
but de nous savons comment faire nous
avons la sécurité sociale de
l'alimentation du transport etc qui peut
transposer dans toutes ses productions
là ce que nous avons fait en 60 dans les
années 60 pour le soin c'est à dire une
socialisation de la valeur au service
d'une fin de dans une caisse de sécurité
sociale de l'alimentation du transport
et cetera
qui va conventionnés des professionnels
on ne va quand mentionné que les
professionnels dissidents bien sûr donc
on va fournir un marché
à
à la barge donc c'est par ce biais là
que l'on met tout ça c'est ça prend du
temps 1 nous savons comment faire nous
avons les figures pour le ferons les
explique longuement dans le bouquin mais
le chemin vers le communisme il se fait
pas en 5 minutes et il n'y aura pas une
prise de pouvoir d'état comme ça dans un
océan de communistes de capitalisme
mondial parce que le capitalisme mondial
aura été
mis en difficulté dans tous les pays
vous êtes aussi optimistes avec laure
dont je crois au scénario bernard mais
pas au même degré que lui je pense que
les conjonctures n'allait comment
dirais-je les les sociétés capitalistes
font en effet face au même problème
elle ne l'est réfléchissent pas tout à
fait identiques mans ni peut-être au
même rythme
donc moi je crains toujours beaucoup le
les effets de désynchronisation des
conjonctures nationales
il me semble pas exclu qu'une
conjoncture révolutionnaires communistes
se forme dans un seul pays et quand
cette fenêtre s'ouvre on l'apprend on
n'attend pas l'armé au pied que les
autres rejoignent pour être parfaitement
pour être parfaitement coordonnée et il
n'est pas impossible que la fenêtre
s'ouvre quelque part qu'elle soit que
l'opportunité soit saisie et que
et que le pays se retrouve seul sur une
scène à la fois je vous connais
économique et géopolitique marqué d'une
réelle adversité
s'il faut bien voir là dedans parce que
toute façon cette cette question c'est
aussi la question de l'internationalisme
bien sûr là il ya un point sur lequel on
est entièrement d'accord bernard et moi
c'est que
le communisme ne saurait se concevoir
autrement que comme un internationalisme
alors moi j'ai une manière un peu
prosaïque d'attraper cette question
d'internationalisme qu'on peut prendre
de plein de façons différentes ma
manière à moi c'est celle d'aix économie
c'est celle de la division du travail
aucun pays si vaste soit il ne peut
imaginer internaliser à lui seul la
totalité des nécessités de sa division
du travail bon voilà
pour la part qu'il n'arrivera pas à
assumer lui même il faudra qu'il ait la
satisfaire en serez insérant dans les
échanges économiques internationaux qui
continueront de baigner dans un nid dans
une logique qui sera qui sera
globalement capitaliste ça pose tout un
tas de difficulté n'est ce pas ça veut
dire que tout simplement il faut mettre
en face des importations et des
exportations
c'est à dire configurer une partie de
l'appareil productif de manière à être
apte à jouer le jeu de du commerce
international capitaliste et c'est ça
mais plein de tension ça mais plein de
tensions partout mais surtout moi
effectivement ce dont j'ai peur c'est
que le pays en question ne se désigne
comme une cible à abattre de la part de
d'autres pays qui seront restés
capitaliste et on sait
on sait que de quelle manière
l'hégémonie capitaliste c'est à dire les
états unis jusqu'à présent à traiter les
dissidences n'est ce pas en amérique
centrale en amérique latine en asie du
sud est c'est le capitalisme et
démocratique ça va sans dire mais
jusqu'au point où on voudrait essayer
autre chose que le capitalisme alors là
démocratique ices absolument de l'être
moi c'est je pense que c'est un argument
si vous voulez kyi qui plaide pour le un
internationalisme comme intérêt bien
compris du pays qui s'avance un peu en
avance des autres dans dans la
trajectoire dans la trajectoire
communiste parce qu'on est fait et là je
pense que bernard à raison d effet
d'émulation il y en aura un je veux dire
quand il se passe quelque chose dans un
pays ça donne des idées dans d'autres
pays donc ça peut hâter la
synchronisation des rythmes et c est en
tout cas ils entrent dans
l'internationalisme devrait à cette
émulation n'est ce pas et de et de
renforcer de densifier tous les liens
entre les multitudes qui sont déjà en
train de mûrir dans la direction du
communisme pour que le processus de
maturation général s'accélère se
synchronise et que le pays qui s'est
avancée seul ne soient plus seuls trop
longtemps je remercie tous les deux
devant pas de cbs cette émission on
travaille conversation sur le communisme
ça vient de paraître à l'est dispute là
il ya tout en détail
nous n'avons fait que survoler un
certain nombre des points que vous
étudiez dans ce livre merci tous les
deux merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
un
des freins à priori du nucléaire c'est
l'émergence dé nouvelles sources
d'énergie aujourd'hui nous sommes le
pays qui produit l'électricité la plus
des carboni au monde on peut rêver à
couvrir de toute la planète de
d'éoliennes mais quand ça produit un
tiers du temps que fait-on pour le reste
à puis il ya aussi la démographie ils en
sont toujours à l'afrique quand même
avec un milliard d'habitants plus la
surface de l'afrique ne soit pas
suffisante pour mettre des panneaux
solaires ou sinon ça se fera au
détriment de l'agriculture on joue aux
apprentis sorciers y compris au niveau
européen quand un pays comme l'allemagne
décide du droit d'arrêter le nucléaire
trouvera les centrales à charbon
l'allemagne est le plus gros pollueurs
européens aujourd'hui aux ja qui a sonné
l'alarmé sur les risques du
réchauffement climatique dit bien que
les besoins en électricité